we can't believer at Hogwarts
no that's Buckingham Palace Hogwarts is
fictional do you know that it's
important to me that you know that okay
guys we are going to be sightseeing
today Andy and Ben are gonna go to their
meeting and then go back to the hotel
for lunch and I will spend the day
getting to know London's history history
began on July 4th 1776 everything before
that was a mistake
Diane suggested we tag along to London
for a honeymoon I agreed because my love
for her Trump's my hatred for Europe
then she hit a phase of morning sickness
that knocked her for a loop and decided
to stay home but she insisted I go and
take pictures for her all of this could
have been avoided if we'd followed my
plan for a honeymoon a steak dinner
a glass of Lagavulin whiskey then
vigorous lovemaking for two hours and
we're both asleep by 8:30 hey let's see
I'm gonna head to the meeting are you
okay yeah I kinda feel bad about leaving
Connie it's like leaving my kid at home
without a babysitter
Leslie you're in London you're 4,000
miles away from home try to enjoy this
okay you're right as usual
good luck so the only thing you did was
stop drinking beer yeah I lost 50 pounds
in one month how much beer were you
drinking no right probably too much Andy
and I are meeting with an English
charity foundation to expand our
after-school music program and British
people love me there was this British
kid in my high school who always called
me Big Ben and would punch me really
hard on the arm and go bong bong bong oh
he might have hated me real quick should
I do a British accent
mm I'm gonna say no you sure yeah I can
do one it's not very good but I think I
could pull it off I just feel like he's
gonna get upset when he finds out that
we're American he knows we're American
oh great all right yes we'll take the
meeting anyway after all we did to the
mole boy down I'm not No
you